are you concerned that the NSA is
tracking you online and doing all kinds
of shady things behind the scenes well
now it's gonna be in front of the scenes
that's right the National Science
Foundation is financing a web service
that is going to monitor quote
suspicious memes on Twitter so now it's
not just there the email that they're
doing on the DL it's everything that you
put out there we've got some more info
for ya the quote truthy database created
by researchers at indiana university is
designed to detect political smears
astroturfing misinformation and other
social pollution that seems like a scary
phrase to me the open source platform
could mitigate the diffusion of false
and misleading ideas detect hate speech
and submerged subversive propaganda and
assist in the preservation of open
debate and a little more while the vast
majority of memes arise in a perfectly
organic manner driven by the complex
mechanisms of life on the web some are
engineered by the shady machinery of
high-profile congressional campaigns
truthy claims to be nonpartisan however
the project's leaders proclaims his
support for numerous progressive
advocacy groups including Obama's
organizing per action move on.org
Greenpeace Amnesty International Sierra
Club and more so that's from the free
beacon and in Indiana you we don't quote
the free beacon here often at the Young
Turks but I thought this was kind of
interesting because it could go either
way right now
Obama is in power and if you don't like
him they could be tracking you and then
you know what a Republican comes into
power and then they could be tracked on
the other guy so I think we have to talk
about this kind of stuff with all the
NSA stuff though is this like does this
seem like nothing to you or does this
seem like this is the stuff that you're
putting out publicly and they're just
getting you know it's not that they're
necessarily it's not that the government
is watching your feed constantly it's
just that they're they're gonna be
aggregating all this stuff and seeing
this is everything true I mean half the
[ __ ] you see on the Internet is not true
probably 90% of it so there's a lot
going on here take it away um well I
have a personal story I have this friend
who
ten years ago was saying sugar causes
cancer you should put tape over your eye
you know your camera on your computer
yeah and I remember there is kind of
people and I remember making fun of her
like oh yeah people are trying to watch
me and you know what two days ago put a
little piece on my camera I mean the
reality is they have been watching or
they they do they've been aggregating
for years and it's it's for people to be
so surprised by it it's silly if you are
on a computer or any electronic device
that can you know have a beacon or
whatever they are what they are capable
of watching you and everyone just needs
to deal with that it's gonna happen for
me I personally don't care cuz the worse
they're gonna find out is I have a
severe case of silly girl itis you know
what I mean like who is doing all the
stuff that they're so concerned the
government is watching Brown but you
never know where you know you don't want
the government have too much power to
just be watching what you're doing all
the time it they just have too much
power they just yeah so is there a
distinction here between like us
policing ourselves because that's what
this is that's why in a weird way that
seems almost more perverse to me like we
know what the government's doing and
it's gross and we complain about it all
the time but this is like you're gonna
be like seeing a meme that you don't
like and like flag it and then it's
gonna go into the database like we're
gonna be watching each other now it's
it's this is like I think that we you
know we live in a world where you know
we were talking about the Islamic state
before they're using Twitter to spread
their propaganda right so I think that
building smarter algorithms to look at
data and mass and organize it in a way
that you know that it makes sense I
think is useful like I was looking at
the website for truthy and it's gonna be
open source you know they have api's
available for you know people to mine
the data and use it for interesting
purposes you know they've got whole
graphics visualization stuff going on um
so I don't think I didn't it didn't
strike me as being necessarily that evil
off the bat you know like it kind of
reminded me of the Obama brain
initiative which i think is amazing you
know and so yeah like I didn't you know
I didn't think it sounded that bad every
time we do one of these stories I
immediately go to the future is gonna be
evil and they're coming to get us but
you will often bring it back to like not
everything that the cars aren't
automatically gonna all kill us and the
robots aren't as the sex robots they're
not going to necessarily strangle you I
have that feeling
techno optimist you know I I choose to
err on the side of optimism because I
think that technology you know true you
know there are some costs to you know
the fact that like I have all of the
world's knowledge in my pocket on my
iPhone I forget I forget numbers a lot
more easily and the like you know I've
outsourced the left brain but I think
that we have a lot more to gain from
technology then then to lose if that
power is you know put into the right
hands and and made as Democratic as
possible I think having a technology
like this being open-source I think is a
sort of good way to you know accomplish
that yeah we did a story on this once
before but you think the internet needs
like a Bill of Rights like something
that supersedes governments but like
just like ten rules that govern the
actual internet and the freedoms and the
rights that we have and what the
government's can and can't do now I know
this is total pie in the sky and they're
never gonna go for it and all that but
like people aren't allowed to post
unless it's verified who they are in
some sense but then on the other hand I
see where that's incorrect and where
that could lead to a bunch of problems
and that being subversive and and
wanting to post anonymously is a
powerful dirty feeling but that being
said if I was on the internet and I was
writing all this terrible things all on
The Huffington Post or wherever it is
and it's anonymous I can't say those
same terrible things to you because even
if you're telling me to shut up I would
pick up that you think I'm crazy
it didn't mean so I do feel like in some
way I wish everyone wouldn't be able to
put stuff on the internet unless it was
verified there's no way to do I wish it
would be that way sometimes is it also
slightly different when people in free
in Western countries do it versus if you
were in Egypt during the revolution you
maybe needed to be anonymous
to be able to get the information out
there about where they should go verse
is what happens in Western societies
where if you go on Huffington Post it's
just anonymous crazy people screaming at
each other so there is some there's some
kind of distinction there right it is
anonymous crazy people here in a but
then you're right and other countries
right right that's true but in other
countries where they're trying to get
some message across and they do need to
be anonymous for their own safety I mean
I do understand that so yeah I don't
know it's a tricky question on that note
as I say everyday don't debate with the
Twitter egg that is pretty much the best
thing that you can do